[Music]
on this sunday night
games over team canada leaves tokyo on a
high note
capping off a record run at the summer
games and the future
is looking up just do what you want to
do do what you love
and just go for it open the gates
starting monday fully vaccinated
american tourists can enter canada even
as covid cases climb to new heights
south of the border and election
rejection
as the trudeau government prepares to
drop the writ how do canadians feel
about heading to the polls
in a pandemic canadians are caught into
an election
[Music]
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
jeff semple
and that's a wrap in tokyo the 2021
summer games went out with a bang today
a spectacular and upbeat ceremony at the
olympic stadium
it was a celebratory atmosphere despite
the lack of spectators
and for team canada there is much to
celebrate
good evening and thank you for joining
us canada's olympians are now heading
home from tokyo
carrying some precious cargo the
canadians captured more medals
than in any other non-boycotted summer
games
team canada earned seven gold medals
tying our total from barcelona back in
1992 a national record
six silvers are also coming home most of
those won on or
in the water along with one from the
track and canada also earned 11 bronze
bringing our total metal count to 24.
the athletes braved intense heat and
unprecedented pandemic restrictions
crystal commansing has more on canada's
record run
from start to finish the tokyo games
captured headlines
the first olympics to be delayed the
first to ban spectators
the first to restrict touching but
canada's 371 athletes
were focused it's still like just slowly
coming in now it's like every time i'm
hearing
gold medalist olympic champion i'm like
oh my gosh it's real it's not a dream
kelsey mitchell's gold on the final day
of the games
propelled canada's medal tally to 24
the nation's second best showing at the
summer olympics
since 1984. i remember when i was
growing up
sitting on the couch and watching
athletes like donovan bailey and katrina
la maydan with my mom on the couch and
seeing how much effect that they had on
my life and inspired me
damien warner carried the flag with a
full
heart at the closing ceremonies he was
crowned
the world's greatest athlete as the
decathlon gold medal winner
canada scored new titles and broke
records in japan
penny oleksiak is now canada's most
decorated olympian
with seven medals andre de grasse won
three medals adding to the three he
earned
in rio not to mention that nail-biting
golden victory
for the women's soccer team
at event after event we witnessed the
quality and the depth of world-class
performances that left us in awe
huge accomplishments under any
circumstances but
even more impressive as the athletes
played in the middle of a pandemic
against the will of many locals
the international olympic committee says
despite 430
coveted 19 cases reported inside the
game's
bubble the competition has been a
success
nobody who took part in these games will
ever forget
these olympic games they are unique and
there are a great manifestation and a
great
symbol of hope it's so nice to race
again it was so nice to compete again
that competitive spirit now in the air
in paris
organizers for the 2024 games will no
doubt have an
easier job than their japanese
counterparts
for the athletes the pressure and desire
to achieve
will be the same crystal gomanson global
news
london and later in the newscast we'll
take a closer look at canada's olympic
young guns who stole the show in tokyo
and the excitement in tokyo isn't over
yet celebrations will ramp
up once again with the opening of the
2021 paralympic games
thousands of athletes from around the
world will compete in 539 events
[Applause]
canada's top paralympians took part in
this new campaign
called we're here it aims to steer the
conversation about canada's paralympians
away from athletic merit
and drive it toward sheer confidence and
even swagger
a total of 128 canadian athletes
including guides will be competing in 18
sports the action kicks off on august
24th
to bc now where firefighters have caught
a much needed break
in the weather clearer skies and calmer
winds are offering temporary reprieve
from fires that have forced thousands
from their homes
many in the okanagan region are furious
with the provincial government
claiming their early warnings were
ignored
matagahi reports from kamloops tonight
well as the residents of fire ravaged
community of monte lake pick up the
pieces
frustration remains over how they may
have been portrayed as irresponsible by
bc officials for staying behind and
defying evacuation orders at the peak of
the fire
there's no one here there's five of us
or whatever there is i don't even know
what the number is
we can't cover it i've not talked to one
bc fire guy
in three days in here there's no other
help no outside help
the wildfire exploded in size and ripped
through the monte lake community on
thursday
and friday it has burned structures and
vehicles but residents
defying evacuation orders say it was
them who saved
any remaining buildings and homes from
the flames
they say leaving was not an option
because they felt they had to protect
properties
among these devastated communities there
are some who are frustrated with what
they say is a lack of official personnel
on the ground in
those areas that suffered the most
damage
people have been screaming for help like
where's the air tanker support
and it's just excuse after excuse it's
just really disappointing to to watch
this thing
and live every day with the anxiety we
are responding with what
uh resources and equipment and all that
that we do have available to us and it
is definitely a top priority and
has been since detection currently
there are more than 100 firefighters 13
helicopters being used
and 38 pieces of heavy equipment on the
ground
the fire hasn't seen much growth since
friday night it still sits at 55
000 hectares now as for conditions
sunday they are favorable for crews it
is cooler
it is humid and there is some rain in
the forecast which will give
those crews a bit of a break because hot
and dry conditions are back
on monday jeff
thanks so much to the pandemic now and
ontario is reporting 423
new cases of covid 19 today that's the
most in the province
since late june and it's a similar
picture right across the country with
cases rising
in many provinces from tomorrow fully
vaccinated americans will be allowed to
cross the border into canada
for non-essential trips as sean o'shea
reports for border towns
it's about time 506 days
that's how long these border bridges
have been closed to americans wanting to
come to canada
i think it's about time for
things to get reopened again only
essential travelers have been allowed to
cross since the beginning of the
pandemic
starting monday american travelers who
follow new rules
are welcome to cross a game we deem to
be fully vaccinated
and also understand it has to be one of
the health canada
approved vaccines for border businesses
here it's like a new beginning
typically 25 percent of the tourists
come from the u.s and they represent 50
percent of the revenue
nearby niagara and the lake that means
more people going for carriage rides
i'm hoping so fingers crossed you know
that's all we can hope for
at the local irish pub many americans
were regulars
they're considered our locals that come
all the time so
not having them for over a year has been
dramatic
at the world famous shaw festival the
theater staged its first indoor
production in more than a year
on saturday night everybody in the poll
place was crying actually it was kind of
the most remarkable moment of coming
back
joyously celebrating together americans
usually make up 40 percent of the
audience
we love those visitors they're so seeing
them start to come back
vaccinated people crossing the borders
makes sense to us and yet as ontario's
coven 19 case numbers start creeping up
again
some canadians are cautious about seeing
foreign visitors cases keep spiking and
just like
driving up numbers of people who aren't
vaccinated we're just going to push our
cases up is just
going to delay our inevitable return to
normal which we're probably never going
to get to
but because visitors must be tested and
vaccinated a surge of tourists is not
expected right away
there's been weddings missed funerals
missed i think that'll be the first
thing families they have a couple
friends who i know they have family on
the other side of the border and it's
been tough for them because like
having been able to see their family in
like yeah like a year and a half now
that wait is now almost over as border
crossings around canada prepared to
allow americans in again
as for when canadians can drive across
the u.s border the american government
hasn't answered that question yet
jeff shawn o'shea reporting in niagara
falls for us tonight thanks sean
and as sean just mentioned canada is
opening its doors to vaccinated american
tourists
despite cases of covet 19 climbing right
across the united states including in
communities
just south of the border take a look at
this map almost every state is now
in the red zone meaning the level of
community transmission
is at its highest even as cases climb
the u.s vaccination rate lags behind
canada and the european union and
hospitals are once again
filling up this week one american father
who chose not to get vaccinated and
became infected
made this desperate plea from his
hospital bed in virginia
for every single birth
like slinging an axe trying to
burst wood
please please go get back today
the u.s is sinking deeper into its
fourth wave
new infections are now at a six-month
high and the rest of the world is once
again
taking notice reggie jacini reports from
washington
the scenes are reminiscent of a time the
u.s thought it might never return to
daily infections are topping 100 000
community spread is now substantial to
high
everywhere including all 11 border
states
it is as we've said a pandemic in an
outbreak
of the unvaccinated this latest wave has
taken a devastating toll on the u.s
south
including florida testing sites are once
again bumper to bumper as the state
breaks records for cases
there are so many people in hospital
elective surgeries are being postponed
with most public health measures to slow
the spread like masking
and capacity limits no longer in place i
think we ought to use every public
health tool we can
when people are dying that becomes
difficult in a place like florida where
politics plays a heavy hand
the state's governor has threatened to
cut off funding if any school
implements a mass mandate but troubling
signs lie ahead
arkansas and georgia which returned to
class last week
have at least 1300 students already in
quarantine
most aren't eligible for the vaccine if
you have a lot of disease in the
community
you may get disease in the school the
whole point is to have disease not
transmitted in the school
while large gatherings are helping to
drive this surge it's the unvaccinated
who are the vector of wave four
as daily deaths spike to around 500
sparking discussions amongst eu nations
that it might be time to shelve inbound
american travel
the block lifted a ban in june as the
u.s appeared to be on a course of
control
non-essential travel could once again be
cut off a move that would see canada one
of the few nations welcoming americans
in
as the country struggles to keep the
virus out now the cdc is still advising
against u.s travel into canada but when
it comes to allowing people across
its borders there's still no criteria a
vaccine mandate is in discussion but it
remains to be seen
if the u.s will require travelers to
have received only fda-approved vaccines
that could omit anyone with astrazeneca
or a mixed dose
jeff reggie chichini in washington
thanks reggie
as american troops pull out of
afghanistan the taliban has seized
three provincial capitals in a single
day
this is the scene in kunduz after the
taliban captured the governor's office
police headquarters and a prison
the city is a strategic crossroads with
access to the country's capital kabul
the taliban also claimed two nearby
capitals but despite the advance the u.s
is moving ahead with the final
withdrawal of its troops
after nearly two decades in afghanistan
still ahead kids and kovid 19 as
unvaccinated children prepare to return
to the classroom
what parents need to know about the
risks
welcome back covet 19 is fast becoming a
disease of the unvaccinated they account
for almost
90 percent of canada's latest cases no
vaccine is approved for children
under the age of 12 who are heading back
to school in just a matter of weeks
with the risk of a possible fourth wave
it's a nerve-wracking time for many
parents
but how worried should they be heather
urix west has this
reality check when desiree mchugh
first noticed mysterious marks on her
teenage daughter last march
she thought it was some kind of rash we
reached out to the doctor
he said it wasn't rashes it's bruising
so just
random bruising showing up all over her
arms her chest her neck her shoulders
her face
just one of several strange symptoms the
15 year old has been struggling with for
months
after a covid19 infection last fall it's
an evolving topic
and we're still really trying to drill
down on quantifying exactly
what is the risk of long covet and what
symptoms do children manifest
dr stephen friedman has been studying
covet 19's effect on
kids for the last year and a half he
says while
by and large children are far less
likely to experience
serious disease it's far from impossible
we do still see some children uncommonly
or infrequently who do become severely
unwell
sometimes during the acute illness but
almost even sometimes more commonly
afterwards when they develop this
inflammatory
syndrome called multisystem inflammatory
syndrome of children
which can result in more critical
illness there have been more than 40
cases of missed c
in alberta alone seven-year-old hunter
mcconnell
became ill following a covet infection
last may
we spent three days in the icu a couple
days
on the other unity still being followed
by cardiology infectious disease
while rare doctors expect to see more
cases of missed c
and long coveted kids through the
delta-fueled fourth wave
parts of the u.s are already seeing more
children in hospital
compared to previous waves it's a little
difficult to say
if the increased number of children that
we're seeing being admitted
with complications of covid is due to
something about
delta intrinsically or is it due simply
to the fact that delta
is such a contagious virus that we're
now seeing
more cases it's why both doctors support
masks in school this fall
particularly for children still
ineligible for vaccine
the risk may be rare but families like
the mccues know
it's not impossible heather urex west
global news calgary
just ahead ottawa prepares for an
impending election but how do canadians
feel about casting a ballot
in a pandemic
there is growing anticipation in ottawa
that a federal election call could come
any day now for weeks the liberal
government has been dropping hints
and the other parties are now preparing
to hit the campaign trail
but with the pandemic still looming
large are canadians really in the mood
for politics
michael couture went to find out
with pandemic restrictions easing across
the country
cities are coming back to life but a
federal election
is looming on the horizon it seems the
average canadian
rather hit a patio than head to the
polls
there's just too much it's fine as it is
right now there's too much going on
let's just let this ride out i think we
don't need
a disruption in policy that's getting
people potentially back to work
canadians are not into an election
they're not feeling especially political
at the moment
pollster daryl bricker says recent
surveys show the majority of canadians
believe the pandemic
won't be done even in the next year so
if an election is called soon he
cautions the liberals against
making the ballot question about how the
government managed the pandemic response
to go out and claim victory and ask for
a referendum on your performance
seems like you're asking for you know
an evaluation of in a hockey game after
the first period
to that end the number of cases of
covid19
are on the rise with the delta variant
continuing to spread
there have been successful provincial
elections during the pandemic
even before vaccines were available
that's why this former liberal
strategist says
opposition parties can't criticize the
liberals
if they do trigger a vote so that's a
tough thing if you're the leader of the
ndp or you're the leader of the
conservatives
when your provincial counterpart held an
election
and perhaps in in the case of at least
one leader you participated in that
election you campaigned for them
in those votes bc premier john horgan
converted his minority government into a
majority
as did blaine higgs in new brunswick
those successes may be what's motivating
prime minister trudeau
as he watches his poll numbers they are
close to majority territory but it's
it's far from a slam dunk
so uh and campaigns matter so a lot of
things could happen during a campaign so
i think
pulling the trigger will be risky but it
could be a risk the prime minister
believes
is worth taking michael couture global
news ottawa
up next passing the torch as the
olympics wrap up in tokyo
team canada's future is looking bright
welcome back there were many magical
moments for team canada in tokyo and it
was often our youngest athletes who
stood tallest atop the podium
canada is traditionally considered a
winter olympics contender but as julia
foy reports a new generation of summer
athletes
is raising the bar drag those knees up
that's it good job sixteen-year-old
caden lee from surrey bc
has been running for several years and
he gets inspiration from the best
i was following closely with andre de
grasse his 200 was the most impressive
especially for me as his kick down the
back stretch was pretty exhilarating to
watch
in the under 18 category caden recently
broke a thunderbird track and field club
record for a mile run
that was set back in 1984. i ran
in the very low four minutes and 12
seconds
i barely inched it out
as the tokyo olympics wrap up and
canadian athletes head for home
some of the youngest superstars
including canada's most decorated
olympian
swimmer penny alexia have a message for
those who will follow their own dreams
just do what you want to do do what you
love and
um just go for it you know what i mean i
think that's something that i've always
tried to
kind of get across at age 14 summer
macintosh is canada's youngest olympian
she says it was never too early for her
to look to the future
it's been a childhood dream of mine
since i was like
five because of my mom and just it was
just such a thing for me i've always
been
quite competitive when it comes to
basically anything so
i'm just really excited to be able to
say that i went to the olympics
a director at western university's
international center for olympic studies
says
we need to build on the success of this
summer olympics
the youth of canada
need a real boost right now and
particularly around physical activity
and sports
so for us to do well in 2024
we have to at least maintain if not
enhance what we have done
previously three two one
as for caden could an olympics be in his
future if i were to compete in the
olympics i would be hoping to compete
in the 1500 or maybe the 5k if i get
stronger
in that event but right now i'd like to
look at
more shorter term goals and i'd like to
see where post-secondary like i said
will bring that to me
next day julia foy global news
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm jeff semple and for the
last day of the olympics
we're going out with a bang a
spectacular finale
above tokyo's national stadium thank you
for origato for watching
have a great night
[Music]
you